secret has managed to get on base in
this series often and in every possible
way
drives this deep out towards right
center field this is carrying back and
this is gone seeger tortures the rangers
again and again and again
home runs in back-to-back days against
texas
it's two-nothing mariners
there we go another look at it comes
right back with another fastball this is
more middle middle at the top of the
zone again
that's right on the barrel
exit v low of 100
396 feet just similar to the home run
yesterday just enough to clear the fence
and give the mariners an early lead
terence the hitter and he'll roll this
one up the middle sliding stop by solac
and they'll get the force out at second
again this was going to be a really
difficult double play to try to turn as
you see nick solak on the backhand and
the slide
and trying to get rid of the ball
quickly he gave elvis a good feed but
the timing of it elvis got that
internal clock he knows there wasn't
enough time to be able to turn it
dylan moore batting second leads it off
clocked out towards center field near
the gap tavares just a spectator gone
goodbye home run dylan moore number six
i'm thinking the wrist is okay
the wrist is okay
he has some serious pop this is a
breaking ball after a couple of high
fast balls curveball middle of the plate
at the knees and he crushed it out to
left center
four and a quarter that is kyle lewis
territory from yesterday
this is a good example for the younger
guys 2-2
out to center field that one sinking
quickly gets down base hit
and it's a 10-game hitting streak
for keiner falefa
and every time he extends it it extends
his personal best
2-1
and that ball shot out to left field
base hit he has one hit against the
mariners today
and the rangers have a couple of base
runners now in this fourth inning
rangers down just three nothing against
this guy
but i would remind you again
certainly gallow can render all of that
a good point here well he most resembles
hercules too on the team that's a good
point if you're talking about a let's
say a herculean effort
hercules is the guy to do it
that ball smoked out to right field it
gets down and we'll go to the wall kind
of felefa is in
two around third they'll wave him here
comes the throw he's down and the
safe
just in there around the tag of terence
and chew looks like he may have hurt his
hand
we mentioned i'll take a look at the tag
here first oh that's why planted with
that right hand so it wasn't even where
the tag was it was just as he hit the
ground he came down kind of hard
directly into the ground didn't hit and
slide the way that he would have wanted
to and it was a little bit of an awkward
slide but yeah wow watch that right hand
go right into the ground
a huge two run double by gallow but
those fingers jammed right underneath
him
so we'll see
now the mariners have crawford on it
first torrance is on its second white is
your runner at third
and here comes dylan moore
here's the payoff
blind left field and a fair ball into
the corner evan white is in to score
terrain's right behind him he's on his
way home here's jp crawford he scores
standing dylan moore have yourself a day
and here you go down and in another off
speed pitch but he stays on it able to
keep it fair
he's out in front of that
keeps it fair
but he just rips it down into the corner
plenty of speed on the bases including
jp crawford the leadoff hitter
and he stands up at second base 6-2
this fine shadow left field for a base
hit dylan moore scores kyle lewis steam
at home
he gets in without a throw
time france drives in two of the
maritals
continue to open this one up even more
eight to two
here he comes with the 3-2 pitch swing
and a miss struck him out brilliant work
by marco gonzalez one two three in the
seventh he's got seven k's in an 8-2
lead here t-mobile park
he really was in command of this game
right away
first pitch strikes a big key for him i
thought today also elevated the fastball
a little more than we're used to seeing
had his changeup working for him just to
kind of slow the rangers down an
aggressive hitting group
they started to mix in his curveball but
it's all about his cutter and his
fastball command and we saw that again
here this afternoon
this one up the middle that's a base hit
for solac it'll get a run to the plate
tavares scores easily
rbi single by solac
still two men aboard and it's now an
eight to three ball game nick solak off
to a little bit of a slow start in this
game but we had talked about in our open
the ability
of both him and isaiah connor for left
against lefties and the matchup they had
against
gonzalez and so now combined they are
three for eight against
3-1
and that one in the air center field
pretty well struck lewis back to make
the catch
connor falefa tags at third he'll score
solac moves up to third base it's eight
to four on the sac fly
going after the first pitch he pops it
up
ramirez is breaking over for it friends
is there to make the catch and in the
ball game